the parents of a teenage girl who died
from an allergic reaction have set up a
groundbreaking clinical trial to
investigate treatments for those with
allergies natasha eden namparooz died
after a severe reaction to a baguette
bought from a pret emoji store back in
2016. she was allergic to sesame it
wasn't listed on the ingredients at the
time as was the law we'll get into the
details of that in a moment and
natasha's parents nadim and tanya edmond
laperus are here and to speak about this
promising clinical trial good to see you
both um i know how hard you've been
working behind the scenes for so long to
get to this point and nadine perhaps you
can tell us about this trial at its
starting point
yeah so the natasha clinical trial is is
a real game-changing moment
in the uk for people with food allergies
it is basically a huge trial across five
university hospitals from the north of
england down to the south of england
where we're going to show
that actually you can use normal shop
bought foods
to be desensitized to the very foods
that you're allergic to
and therefore
onwards from the trial under clinical
supervision you can be you'll be able to
eat in fact the very foods that you were
allergic to and that were actually
inadvertently poison for you when now
the food will become in fact the remedy
for your for your food allergy it's an
amazing moment it's a traditional
science that dates back about 100 years
and what we're doing is we're just
bringing this science essentially into
the modern moment
and doing it at scale to show that it
can be done as a very cost effective way
for the nhs to treat millions of people
in the uk
yeah tanya i'm no scientist i'm no
expert on clinical trials but just
reading the background to this it does
sound like such a simple idea and as
adam says this has been tried and tested
before it's basically introducing
things that people are allergic to like
milk and peanuts which are you know some
of the more common allergies
introducing them slowly into someone's
diet to build up a tolerance is that
correct
that's right and over about a year you
take incremental tiny amounts and it
goes up a little bit and your immune
gets used to it and you actually get to
a point where you can tolerate
quite a lot of that allergen without
reacting
and
it's like like nad said it's something
that's been around for a long time um
but it could make such a big difference
because if we think of people with food
allergies and the smallest amount of
food can actually hospitalize them or
even kill them we don't with this um
treatment we don't have to worry about
may contain labels we don't have to
worry about
cross-contamination and and they can
actually even eat that food every single
day to stay out of allergy yeah um nadia
obviously the goal here is to save lives
but it's also to change lives as well
because obviously you lived with this
because of natasha and her allergy to
sesame
and
she had to be very careful when she ate
out and she was literally making life or
death decisions so just talk to me about
if this was to be successful how
life-changing it would be for hundreds
of thousands of people because food
allergies are much more common than many
people realize
that's right it's just really important
for your listeners and the viewers to to
know that food allergy is a disease of
the immune system
and it not to confuse us with
vegetarianism or veganism which are
lifestyle choices
and we're talking about food allergy
which can kill you or seriously
hospitalize you and the numbers of
people who are food allergic in the uk
and indeed in most developed countries
of the world are shooting up to
and also not in terms of
the numbers alone but what they're
allergic to so they're now people are
allergic to so many different foods when
i think when we were all children
growing up maybe we knew somebody who
was allergic to peanuts but now it's
moved on a lot and what we're really
going to show here is just how dramatic
and positive effect it can be on on
families
on their day-to-day lives that revolve
around food because after all we all
have to eat in order to live by actually
being able to eat the food that you're
allergic to
you are brought back into the normal
food economy
and you're not reliant on any form of
drugs or some kind of pharmaceutical if
you like it because food is the remedy
so food becomes the medicine and you can
participate in all the happy things the
families do like eating out or enjoying
family meals together rather than
avoiding them entirely
um
taney can i just say what a legacy you
are creating for your daughter natasha
our viewers will be well familiar uh
with natasha's law that came into effect
in october it was brought in making
allergy information a requirement for
food made on site because obviously
uh the food product that natasha ate was
made in-house on a premises and at the
time the law uh was such that you didn't
have to list all the ingredients and
you've changed that
and now you are doing more you're not
stopping
tanya this is enormous what you're doing
and all in natasha's name
yes it is in her name and um i think
that the turning point for us was after
natasha's inquest um we had no idea that
the numbers the biologies people with
allergies being diagnosed with them
had gone up in the last two decades as
they had done and we received so many
letters from families saying what's
happened to you is what we fear the most
and we live in fear every day
and so we know that natasha's law closed
a loophole in the law and that was
really important to give people clarity
and information about the food they're
eating
but really you know there's so much more
that needs to be done and this will
directly impact a lot of people and just
take that um
the terrible stress that people with
food allergies live with and we hope
that will take it away so they can just
have more hope of leading more normal
life
um
i think
we want to say that that's so important
so important that the idea of normal
lives um i think for people who don't
have food allergies they have no idea
just how stressful life is for families
who have children with allergies because
they live in fear that we
are the family you know that have the
worst tragedy story that that could
happen to them and and we you know tanya
and i have said along with our son alex
that we're going to dedicate
really the rest of our lives to try and
helping people with food allergies and
natasha's trial is a big big sort of
move towards just doing that
well it is incredible work you're doing
as you've said in natasha's name
and so many families around the world
will be looking at you and thanking you
for going to such efforts because as you
said it is
terrifying for families and isolating as
well for so many children growing up and
nadine and tania eden lamparooz thank
you so much for talking to us here on
sky news and best of luck with the
clinical trial we hope to catch up with
you soon about it thank you
thank you as well much appreciated thank
you